what I'm gonna try and do is Aaron and I
struggled with this a little bit I never
want to just give you an answer because
ultimately just giving you an answer is
actually not going to help you to work
out the answer next time because you'll
need someone else to give you the answer
so I'm gonna try and walk you through
the path I took to get my solution I'm
actually gonna show it to you twice
because the first solution I came up
with was alright but there's a much
better one and I only worked it out
afterwards okay so let me just guide you
through my thought process this is what
we're trying to prove okay and the first
thing I wanna know is I've seen some of
you are more than one of you convert
this into degrees and then solve fire
prove the identity in degrees okay now
it's strictly speaking there's no
problem with that
like if you solve this if you provided a
solution in degrees and it works thumbs
up like degrees and radians just
alternative measures however I'm just
going to put you put this question to
all of you why might it be in my
interest to not do this in degrees but
to do it in radians it's not a
rhetorical question what might be the
point why in fact did I bother give you
an exercise you've actually seen before
but pulled out all the questions in
radians on purpose how long ago did you
meet radians how long ago a week we can
be it may be right so this is a new idea
for us it's a new category in your brain
and you have to get used to using this
category because it's what you need to
do calculus on all these things okay
so sort of the whole point here is to
get your brain like to shape it into a
different thing like you know be
flexible enough to with your with your
mind to work with these the same way
you're comfortably working in degrees so
I'm going to leave everything in radians
okay now my second question to you is
which way will I go I'm required to
prove this identity do you think it
makes more sense to go from the left to
the right or to go from the right to the
left which does your instinct say -
thing says left - right now you can do
either it's an equation so the sides
that are equal but our brains are
generally better
working with a complicated object and
turning it into a simple object does
that make sense okay so I'm going to
work with the left-hand side here I'm
gonna say it left hand side equals and
I'm just going to write it as it stands
and then I pause for a moment okay now
there are two different directions you
can go in and I'm going to first show
you the most obvious one that came to me
this is in the form to sign a cos B yep
the angles do not match if they did
match that'd be double angle for same
that would be nice I can just use that
formula but they don't match which
presents me with an issue okay so I
haven't look at all of these results
that I was we were thinking that in
deriving earlier right and I noticed
that this sign a cos B it only comes up
in two of the six identities do you
notice which to which two is it it's the
first two right it's this one and this
one okay there's a sign a cos B in each
of them but I noticed that over here on
this right hand side there's like stuff
that I'm supposed to get that's not
there like there's missing there's no
cause a sine B that comes along for the
ride so whatever this came from the
Khans a sine Mays have somehow vanished
right now there's lots of ways you can
get rid of something but especially
being that I have everything on the
board and I'm gonna get rid of these now
because they're irrelevant
especially as I have them on the board
there's a way you can think back to your
algebra and all of your solving
equations stuff that you know from there
there's a way using these two objects
together that I can get rid of these
cause a sign B's that I don't have over
here what could I do to these two
objects that would eliminate them think
if you've got a plus here and a minus
here then like if you had simultaneous
equations this is crying out to add
these equations together and then both
of these are gone does that make sense
not only are both of them gone but how
many of these will you get you will get
two that looks good doesn't it okay so
here's what I'm going to say
this is a bit of a long form way of
writing it but again it's a proof so I'm
gonna lean towards writing things in a
long way I'm going to add and subtract
this same term if you add and subtract
it it's the same object right so I've
got this to sign four PI over five cause
I own five I'm going to add this cause a
sine B term let's see here because yeah
sign yeah like that but I'm also going
to subtract it so this is very similar
to what we did with say rationalizing
the denominator when you dealt with cert
you multiplied by something and you also
divide by it well here I'm adding and
I'm subtracting so there's no net change
okay so one more thing than I do which
makes this a bit easier to see the
connection right see how this to hear
what's because they collected like terms
if I unn collect the like terms and put
them separately like that do you see
what I've got now this guy up here is
this first identity and this one down
the bottom is the second do you see why
I've written it in that way so now I can
substitute all of this long stuff for
this shot stuff I'm doing a trig
expansion does that make sense so what
some what am I a and B four point five
and five and five
so therefore when I have a plus B when
you add those two together you get think
four point five five and five you add
them and you get PI yep
that's the whole first thing there okay
when I do the second one it's a
subtraction right so if this is 4 point
5 minus point 5 what do you get 3 prime
5 right now this point you ought to get
really suspicious because if you're
getting more comfortable using radians
now you know that pi is equal to how
many degrees it's a hundred and eighty
degrees and you know what sign looks
like don't you there it is
where's a hundred degrees where's PI
radians it's right there sorry this
badly
metrical bit there you go that's the
point I'm interested in so that's zero
plus this now at this point you're
either cheering or really upset because
you're like that's not what a host of
hosts again right but if you've done
everything right which we have then
these two things should be equal and
they are how can you prove that they are
what's the difference between three
point five or I should say what's the
relationship between three point five
entry point five what are they they're
start with an S long word this
supplementary aren't they they add 2 pi
but that's an identity that I can use
right sine of 180 minus 30 sine of 150
is the same as sine 30 so that is the
sine 2 pi + 5 that was required okay so
this way works and it uses all the
knowledge that you've got but then who
can I realize that I could have done
this you know how when you do a trig
identity you prove that one thing equals
another there's are lots of ways to do
it
I'm sure there's like five or ten ways
to do this okay as soon as I realized
that I had to do this I realized I could
have done it earlier and that would have
been helpful when could I have done this
have a look at your working I could have
done this this PI - whatever angle I
could have done it right up here watch
what happens if we do it early okay and
then um and get ready to cry this is 2
sine 4 PI + 5 cos PI + 5 that's the
first thing okay now where shall I use
this I think I should use it here you
see it do you see what's about to happen
right this is 2 sine of Pi take away 4
PI o + 5 that's the identity I just used
right there is that ok cos PI on 5 how
are you going with getting used to these
PI's in these fractions what's pi minus
4.5
and said again what's pi minus 4pi and
five it's it's just pie in five right oh
snap
there's that double angle which I'm so
good at seeing when it's degrees but I'm
not so good at seeing when it's radians
okay